something that is is hovering over the
national football league the cloud is
growing especially for the person
at the center of it but there are two
people at the center of it on one hand
you have desean watson the texans
quarterback who
is the target now of at least two
lawsuits alleging
assault during massages
and the lawyer the other person at the
center of this chris tony busby
a notorious famous
flamboyant lawyer in houston
who claims that there are four more
that are going to be filed four more
individuals the first two have operated
under the jane doe
pseudonym that's not an uncommon tactic
for people who are trying to
maintain privacy and discretion when
they pursue claims like this but
busby who's been active on social media
the past
few days yesterday afternoon mentioned
that the second claim was going to be
filed and then
last night there was another post which
disclosed that
there would be six in all i assume
but i don't know i assume based on the
first two that these claims are all
basically the same allegation
during a massage there was
something that made the masseuse
uncomfortable
some degree of contact although
it's not like going to the dentist i
mean when you're getting a massage it's
all premised on contact
some degree of contact that made the
masseuse uncomfortable
that resulted in a lawsuit and the
lawsuits the two of them and there's a
lot of similarity a lot
a lot of copy and paste between the two
lawsuits right
on one hand it's not about the money but
then
at the bottom line it's about the money
so
i don't know what it's about i don't
know what the motivation is
if deshawn watson did the things he's
alleged
to have done you know you're gonna have
different people who react to this and
say
i i don't know what he did if he's
guilty of what he's alleged to have done
because it's not the traditional
yeah right sexual assault
it's a massage at some point the
masseuse became uncomfortable
and didn't disengage the instant
the discomfort should have arisen right
continued
and then there was contact of some sort
not the normal type
and then disengagement so that's the
pattern so far that's two
yeah there's four more let's see what
the next four look like but
that's kind of where we are and and look
is this significant well yes because at
a time when the texans seem to have
accepted the fact they have to trade the
guy
how if you're another team can you trade
for a player who has not won
but two and supposedly four more
of these clouds that would need to be
explored
before you could feel comfortable making
a trip
agree agreed i mean there's no way a
trade's happening anytime soon
i just can't i can't imagine how can you
do that
in this time in this day and age 2021
the current environment we have in our
country and all the issues like
i just can't imagine a team is going to
be looking to trade for deshaun watson
anytime
soon until there's more answers and and
things like that more
facts of the situation that come to
light
but you know nonetheless it's
it doesn't look good for desean watson i
mean and again i'm not trying to say
he's guilty right now and i know he'll
have his day here in court and all that
type of stuff
but it's not a good look and you know
once you start to see
more than one person that always kind of
scares me a little bit
that does and um it's a shame to see
because i just never imagined that
desean watson would
you know put himself in some of these
situations
i guess that's where i'm a little
shocked like an instagram
masseuse and you're gonna you know play
those type of games and again i'm not
trying to say he's guilty we'll see
where it goes but it certainly doesn't
look good
and here's the other thing mike can i
just say this real quick like
with tony busby you know listen i i
he's a good lawyer and i'm all for him
defending these women and doing what
he's got to do
but like get out of here with like
teaching me about the integrity part
like shut up tony busby can we at him
right now while we're doing the show
because like seriously i mean he's the
biggest trump supporter
in houston and he didn't seem to have
any issue with
what double-digit people coming forward
women about trump so that's not the only
thing i'm going to say there
but that bothers me that this this hip
hypocrisy that's going on in our society
right now
oh now he's going to stand on a table
and tell us that
he can't believe how irrational people
are yet
like he he swiped it under the rug with
the great trump
you know god king oh okay so shut up
with that tony busby
and we'll see where this goes with
desean watson because yeah it's
troubling it bothers me i'm a big fan of
him i was a big fan of him as a person
and
right now that's kind of in shambles
the there's a vibe
coming from the watson camp that i've
detected
and it goes a little like this
obviously he denies doing anything sure
improper
and will deny it and is determined
to spend whatever he has to spend to
clear his name that was the gist of his
original social media post that made me
first aware
of the problem on tuesday night before i
saw
anything about the tony busby side of it
but when you read
these materials yeah when you look at it
you say if we accept all of this is 100
true what really
is this i i think there's enough
there to proceed you know the first line
of defense in a civil action if you
choose to take it is to file a motion to
dismiss for failure state acclaim and i
don't want to get into any continuing
legal education here for folks but the
bottom line is
what you do is you go into court you say
if everything they're claiming
is 100 factual there's nothing that the
legal system
can or will do about it now i think
based on my reading of the two
complaints and my 19 years experience
practicing a lot i'm not doing that oh
it breaks a lot
i'm just saying it's i'm not just just
speaking out of an
orifice here i'm i've seen these i've
evaluated these from both sides
there's enough there to go forward but
the question is what's there at the end
of the day
right what what's what's the end game
here
is it money is it something else is it
tony busby's
just i don't i i don't know i don't know
like
why are you i mean i'd like to know how
did he
here's what happened here's what
happened right the
first social media post that tony busby
put on instagram a couple of days ago it
actively solicits
anybody else out there here's where you
contact me
and and i i it's been a long time since
i practiced law and i'm happy to have
gotten over the wall
and escaped and trust me plenty of
people who practice law
would love to find a way out it is a
stressful life you're in the middle of
fight if you're a litigator you're in
the middle of fights like this
all the time it gets personal gets ugly
gets nasty it wears on you
but i can't remember or i've forgotten
or which is the same thing or i never
really fully understood what the rules
were for solicitation because that was
never my style i
you know in my mind there's a there's a
wall there and you need to be careful
about how far you go
to say hey anybody who wants to come out
of the woodwork and sign up we're going
after
x whatever person or company it may be
but he did that
he did that on tuesday and it may be
entirely appropriate
but that's how you end up potentially
with six now the question is
what's the quality of each case what's
the quality of the evidence is there
other stuff
that tony busby doesn't know about
because these things seem a little bit
rushed and one of the points he
addressed in social media
yesterday was i fully vetted all of
these folks but
you know each one of these has to be
assessed on its own
merits the problem is
with the exception of the person you
mentioned earlier where there were more
than 20 that stacked up and nobody
seemed to care
everybody cared i mean and he he's all
the outrages for the guy the biggest
fundraiser in houston that's where i
just that's bothers me and i'm not
giving letting desean watson get a free
pass for that at all
i'm mad at desean watson and it doesn't
look good
but i i don't want to hear that crap
don't preach to me when you got your own
issues there buddy
for the average normal person as these
things start to stack up
there is a critical mass where you just
say
something's not right here and and i
think that's
the fair conclusion right now
preliminarily still early in the process
something's not right here
something something doesn't add up here
and
i i i don't know how much of the
litigation going forward will expose
whatever the motivation hopefully the
truth comes out one way or the other
and and you know the other message in
all of this to
professional athletes out there
especially the most prominent and
wealthy
the ones who are most likely to be
targets if you do believe you have been
targeted you got to watch these
situations where you can end up with
he said she said and no way to prove
yeah right that you're right right
if if you truly are innocent you got to
be very careful
about who you welcome into your hotel
suite
the second lawsuit chris followed by a
masseuse who was flown from atlanta to
houston
by deshaun watson and the massage
happened in his hotel suite you got to
be careful who you trust
you got to be careful where you go you
got to be careful what you do
because every one of those interactions
and i'm not saying morally right or
wrong or otherwise or whatever you think
is going to happen going into it
one of those interactions could turn out
exactly the way you thought they were
going to once you initiated contact on
instagram
and then you find out later that the
person you're dealing with has a
different interpretation
a different agenda a different
motivation or is just upset
that the person never got another phone
call i mean that that's a risk you're
taking
if you never do anything other than
the most gentlemanly consensual behavior
you still run that risk when you're
dealing with strangers and
i that i think you know to the extent
they still have a rookie symposium and
they don't anymore
i think players nowadays need to be
aware of that risk that they're taking
assuming they don't do anything wrong
again i'm not saying that in this case
we don't we gotta deal with these
because that's a problem you're gonna
find yourself in a spot like this no
doubt
allegations are made and you have to
defend yourself even if you did nothing
that's the risk you're taking no
potential you're right it is a real risk
it's something you got to watch out for
as an nfl football player
listen my wife early on in my career in
in
tampa bay you know there was there was a
a
a player on the team who referred to
masseuse to me
right the masseuse was very attractive
good looking she comes to the apartment
does that but my wife stayed
you know in the apartment and even after
and she made like you know i just i just
want to make sure everything
goes good i don't want anything to you
know she was aware of kind of what
you're saying
you know i i can't remember her exact
quote or exactly what you said but
that's
that's a real thing as an nfl football
player or a star
player in general you got to be careful
of the situations you put yourself in
and to me
that's like the first thing you look at
with desean watson yeah i'm disappointed
it doesn't look good
if he's guilty he's some real jerk i'll
tell you that
and then but the other thing i just go
what were you i mean you're going to a
masseuse's house
you're flying somebody from atlanta like
that's you're playing with fire there
and that's where
um you know of course now he's he's in
trouble and we'll see
and like trade done there's no way
that's happening
i i'd be shocked if it happens this
season
or this offseason at all now because
like you said yesterday there's gonna
it's gonna be some time here before some
of this gets figured out and flushed out
and we start to get a little bit better
of a a real picture
of the reality of the situation and that
might not be till next off season
so that to me ends that conversation for
the most part with desean watson and i
can't imagine anyone trying to trade for
him in this current environment right
now
unless detections just slash their
expectations because they
come to the conclusion that they can't
continue the relationship
i i don't know that they will i don't
know that they should
i they could though and that's one thing
to put on the radar screen the
possibility the texans just get to the
point where they
they take less than the three first
round picks or whatever the package
would be
to get their attention because they
believe the relationship
moving forward is untenable i just don't
think that
if these and yeah we got to see what
these other four lawsuits say right
one of the social media posts from tony
busby said the third one that's going to
be filed is the most egregious chat and
i don't know how much of this is
carnival barkering by tony busby
i'd rather let the documents speak for
themselves and i'm analyzing every one
of these that come
through we'll see but if these are all
cookie cutter same
six it it just say you know same set of
facts
because a massage is an inherently
intimate act that that's
yes it's it it's this is not going to
the dentist
and having something like this happen
that's what makes it different again i'm
not
saying that that desean watson has a
license
to engage in a program conduct i know it
just goes back to your point
right man given what a massage is
there are places where you can go
where you don't get yourself into what
my dad would have called a jackpot and i
never did understand why a jackpot was a
bad thing i thought you tried to win a
jackpot but anyway the
you you don't get yourself into this
situation right an inherently intimate
act
at the house of someone you don't know
right with no
witnesses and it's all going to come
down at the end of the day to what you
say
and what she says that is
a recipe for exactly
what deshawn watson is dealing with now
no no right or wrong whatever he did or
didn't do
it is a recipe for what he's dealing
with now no that's where the stupidity
start it started you're right that that
was the jump off point to
we'll see whether he did or didn't do
the rest here going forward i mean again
like i said i'm i'm disappointed
but into that mic too just a little bit
you know and i know there's
you know the the talk of the massage and
the groin area like
that you know the intimacy of it for a
football player and i'm not trying to be
some pervert here or anything like that
for a football player where your life is
squatting and getting down and sprint
there's not a place
through my career where i was more sore
on a regular basis
than my upper thighs my groin my butt
in fact when i had masseuses where i was
like oh can you get my glutes a little
bit because
you know i've squatted or got hit with
helmets there and all that
you know every now and then i had a
woman to say i'm not comfortable with
that okay that's cool
but that was the last time i was going
to see her because my glutes were
important i needed them rubbed on i
had i needed somebody that was going to
be able to you know break that barrier
down and go into those areas
and i wasn't going to get weird with
them or anything like that
but that's where you're legitimately
sore too and for an athlete there is
that aspect and again i i don't know
where deshawn watson went with it after
that
but that is a real aspect of what you're
trying to get done to
rehab fix yourself as a football player
or an athlete
all the more reason to have work like
that done in
a facility yeah right everyone's
licensed and everyone knows how it works
and there are procedures and
calls and you're not going to someone's
house with no witnesses or flying
someone from atlanta
to a hotel in houston with no witnesses
where at the end of the day
you are in a situation potentially where
your version
is here her version is here
and you have to spend a lot of money
a lot of time a lot of effort and a lot
of worry
trying to vindicate your version of what
happened and it gets more and more
difficult
as it goes from one to two to three to
six
that's the problem that sean watson
faces so
so chris uh this all is happening
yeah as our friend john mclean of the
houston chronicle right dean of the
sports scene in houston who on january 7
said i've got a better chance of being
the next coach of the texans
than desean watson has of being traded
because that's the message he was
getting from the team
right yesterday he tweets i now believe
desean watson will be traded
and we've we've talked about these
practical impediments but it it's
that's the great i don't know if irony
is the right word here because i never
know fire and he's the right word thank
you alanis morissette but that's the
great potential irony here
as the texans come to the conclusion
that they are willing to trade him
these external events are emerging
that may make it impossible to trade him
right i i
agreed i mean first off you know you
know like you said
when john mcclay is like tom curran up
in boston it's when john mclean talks
you know in houston and he's talking you
listen
he's been there forever he's the man
i've known him since my days playing at
texas i mean
he is the man you're right he's the
godfather maybe sports writer and the
whole state of texas
as far as that's concerned you know but
but i you know again i don't know maybe
at that time when he put that out he
wasn't quite aware of maybe the
the situation as a whole right mike i
mean that's all i could say there but
again i can't imagine that anything goes
down i really can't
you know that's a dicey situation for
any football team
to bring him in with all this hanging in
the balance
and then you're gonna have to deal with
the backlash from
you know people fan base everything like
that
why did you trade for this guy all
football players though we're all
swiping
under the rug because he's a football
player or star they're allowed to do
anything and that's a conversation that
i don't think any coaching staff or
organization wants around their team
also before we heard of the additional
lawsuits right filed when it was just
one joe person of the athletic
said that uh the panthers were locked in
on trading for deshaun watson and
actually i think person
reported that before there was even one
assault lawsuit that had been filed but
you know the panthers obviously
i get it it was before there was any of
this the panthers are desperate for a
franchise quarterback
we don't know whether or not deshaun
watson would take a trade
to the carolina panthers because unlike
russell wilson we haven't gotten a
a public list of the teams he played for
but that that
is at this point secondary to
the issues that flow from and you know
you may have people out there
who would reasonably say well what's
this have to do with his employment and
you know what for most
employers and employees in the country
it has nothing to do with it because as
long as you haven't been criminally
charged and you can show up for work
every day
you show up but the nfl implemented a
personal conduct policy
and in 2014 in the aftermath of the ray
rice case the nfl
created an in-house justice system that
it will activate
right parallel to if it chooses the
civil or criminal justice system
and the nfl officially had no comment
yesterday they were aware of the lawsuit
well they're going to be aware of six of
them soon
what do you do at what point do you
investigate at what point do you bring
to sean watson and at what point do you
try to identify
the individual alleged victims it's very
easy to track down tony busby puts his
email
on social media hey mr busby we're from
the national football league and
we have an obligation to investigate
these situations we would like to have
an opportunity to interview
your clients yeah they either will
cooperate or they won't and
chris this this is this is the last
thing i'm going to say about this before
we move on yeah
and this is my advice to sean watson
assuming that he's never done anything
inappropriate
during these massages and that he would
ultimately prevail
or regardless of whether or not a judge
or a jury believes him because trust me
there are plenty of legal proceedings
where
you're right but the system says
otherwise sure
if desean watson did not do anything
wrong my advice to him would be very
simple
just just whatever it costs settle these
cases just
make them go away and i know that's hard
for people i know
if you if you did nothing wrong right
but
call it a tax on your naivete or
stupidity yeah
putting yourself in these situations
that's a good point and just make make
it go away because you can
legitimately include in these
settlements
an agreement that without a subpoena
there will be
no cooperation with anyone no
communication with anyone about any of
the details
and the nfl reaches a dead end and there
could never be
the nfl coming to a conclusion that
would be a miscarriage of justice
if you truly never did anything wrong
now if you did something wrong with a
different conversation
but if you truly believe that you did
nothing wrong and there was nothing
inappropriate
even though it's counter to this notion
of defend yourself
and clear your name there's there's
value in considering the possibility of
resolving these claims
and getting a commitment that if the nfl
decides they're going to activate
the process we saw what happened to
ezekiel yeah we've seen what's happened
to other guys right guys who were now
ezekiel was never
criminally charged or sued and he was
suspended six games by the nfl because
there was a motivated victim
who spoke to the nfl six times and they
ultimately believed her
right despite and unlike other people
despite people in the league office
all right saying i don't believe her
right right right they still got him
yeah that's what you want you want to
avoid that potential for that arbitrary
roll of the dice that you're a guy that
they decide for whatever reason they're
going to come get it
that's a tough one it's really tough as
you know an athlete because of what that
clear your name thing right you want you
want to be able to say like listen this
is this is bs this is not real
i'm going to fight it i'm not going to
let them get away with this but
the reason people do settle even when
they're not guilty at times right
is because in the court of public
opinion as this goes on
you know you're guilty there's just even
if you get found not guilty two years
from now everyone's just gonna look at
it and go oh yeah
you mean that quarterback with the
massage girls and all that that guy
yeah well he was not guilty oh i doubted
but that's what happens so i don't know
we'll see we
i know we're not giving desean watson
any free passes here certainly not
right we'll see but it's a weird
situation altogether
he certainly put himself in some stupid
situations
and now we just sit back and and kind of
watch the facts come out and and see how
this plays out but please tony busby
spare me spare me your your crap and
telling me about
how to treat woman and all that type of
crap when you're god king is donald
trump shut up
okay thank you let's talk about one i
said one last point but let me add this
to you i know there's a concern that if
you start reaching these settlements if
you've done nothing wrong there's going
to be another and another and another
and another
you know what until you get to the point
where someone makes an allegation
against you and you can truthfully say i
don't even know who this person is
if you've put yourself in these spots
this intimate process of a massage with
no witnesses at people's homes
in hotel rooms people flown from atlanta
this is
what you are risking
no doubt you are risking this that
you're going to be falsely accused and
there's no way that you're going to be
able to conclusively prove
that you didn't do anything wrong hi i'm
mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports